hey youtubers its charlie thank you
everybody that submitted questions on my
episode 1 video earlier this week I know
a lot of you weren't huge fans of the
black and white they use the way they
edited the episode just remember they do
try to get really creative with the
intros every once in a while as much
[ __ ] is going on right now I think this
episode is really gonna go down as the
legend of the protein bar that was like
the biggest thing I heard people talking
about right after the episode so just
careful for spoilers as we get into
questions starting with number 1 se asks
what's with the crazy booby-trapped Town
Morgan making a brief appearance did you
take my protein bar well uh Morgan isn't
a brief appearance he's gonna be a
series regular for at least the first
part of the season I don't know if he's
gonna be here for the second half I
certainly hope so he's really
interesting Lennie James status is to be
determined I believe he's a series
regular currently though but he's
talking about something from season
three its season three episode 12 where
he Michonne and Carl go back to his
place you see Michonne eating in the
background I know she's at least eating
chips she may have also eaten the
protein bar I think that's the consensus
that she definitely ate the protein bar
she does get called on eating stuff in
the episode her responses the Matt said
welcome so like who cares the showrunner
Scott Gimple after the episode said that
he was actually like really blown away
at how people were upset over her maybe
taking the protein bar his response was
just like hey you know there's a lot of
terrible stuff happening let her have it
let her have the protein bar in the
context of the episode that was really
just him saying hello to Michelle kind
of feeling her out again so it's really
not a conversation about a protein bar
at all it's just him reaching for a
shared experience that they have
something that they have in common next
question Ozzy asks do you think that if
fear The Walking Dead did not have the
Walking Dead in the title it would be as
popular no I mean it definitely wouldn't
be as popular but you could say that of
Star Wars or anything else that's part
of a franchise like if they did a Star
Wars spin-off movie with characters
you've never seen before in a different
part of the galaxy would you know it was
a Star Wars movie if they didn't tell
you just from a marketing perspective
figure if you were to do a spin-off of
any big franchise it would be the worst
decision in the world to not use the
title of the really famous thing that
you're spinning off but the different
thing that they've done with fear The
Walking Dead is that it's not like them
taking characters they've already
established and create
another series based on them it's like
characters that we've never met before
that's the weird part
next question gamer Insurgentes asks it
might just be me seeing it but do you
reckon that they are intentionally
portraying Rick as an antagonist or am I
crazy or maybe both no they're
definitely trying to make you think that
Rick is the antagonist that's just them
messing with us of course Rick is the
protagonist they just want you to feel
like there's gonna be conflict in the
group you can't get too mad at the
writers for stirring the pot that way
just because this is a drama it's as
much a gritty drama as it is a genre
show you know like comic book Sambi for
rick is just like the next logical step
for his character last season though I
think is when he hit the boiling point
when Michelle just cold clocked him and
knocked him right out next question
Gabriel asks do you think that Rick and
Morgan will remain friends if not who do
you think would be the one to end the
friendship you know I don't think that
they're gonna like ever completely break
up I think that Morgan eventually will
pass on if he doesn't end up dying but
he is so firmly entrenched in his new
philosophy like this crazy weird Jedi
wanderer philosophy that he has but I do
think he will be one of the few people
who won't completely drink Rick's
kool-aid so at a certain point he'll
have to either drink that kool-aid
completely like completely become a
survivor or he'll have to go somewhere
else but even if that ends up happening
I don't think that they would have like
a major falling out but you know they'd
be at each other's throats like Rick and
Shane Morgan isn't gonna dig Laurie's
corpse up and try to take Rick's family
from him again
next question soccerstar asks this may
not be a direct for this exact episode
but Carol seems to be still acting
useless how do you think the Beth would
act if she was in Alexandria if Carol
died and she survived
well you and pretty much everybody else
Beth has her fans but carol is the
better character I think if Beth were
still alive what they might have ended
up doing is giving her the Ark that
sasha has right now where she goes super
hardcore just starts carrying an
automatic weapon around like it's her
boyfriend which I guess means that it
would end up dying sometime during the
episode the joke about Beth's
boyfriend's are that they all die really
really quickly if you want to get rid of
like any of the male characters on the
show just have them go out with Beth
next question and judge Holden asks
wouldn't have been just easier to burn
the Horde in the quarry all the work to
get the route set up yeah you're talking
yeah why go through all that trouble if
they could just throw some fire bombs
and
Corie well one because I think they
wanted to have that big drawn-out drama
like there wouldn't be an episode if
they didn't do that
the second reason and the one that I
think is more important is this because
even though it's Rick's idea part of the
drama of the show is characters making
really bad decisions and it completely
messing everything up so the fun for us
is just seeing the Walker problem just
blow up exploding guts all over
everyone's faces next question Michael
asks who out of the Alexandria folk
would you say is most likely to turn
against Rick or try to take control of
the community well I mean I don't think
that anybody is going to try and wrestle
control from him Deanna's technically
still in charge even though they're
deferring a lot to Rick I think of
anyone's gonna be causing problems for
the community it's probably gonna be
Enid or some of the new characters that
we don't know a lot about yet there is
one new character that we haven't met
yet there's a comic book character that
the show is bringing on called Denise
Cloyd she's gonna be like the new doctor
but I don't think that she's gonna be a
character that's gonna cause a bunch of
problems for everyone she's relatively
benign next question Gabriel asks do you
think that Carl will lose an eye to this
season well there's been there's been a
lot of weird pictures from this set I
try to avoid spoilers for The Walking
Dead because there are so many there are
so many spoilers but I generally don't
expect any characters to get maimed long
term just because it would be really
weird for actors to have to live with
that further the next like three seasons
like the governor lost an eye
Merl lost a hand there they're probably
a little bit better at acting through
stuff like that Chandler Riggs great kid
but we really don't even know what his
arc is this season and he's not the
strongest actor on the show and and
generally things like that can feel kind
of gimmicky like oh we're just gonna
hurt this character to make them
interesting I can't really say no
they're not gonna maim him I mean I
don't know if they're gonna do that but
it really just depends on where his arc
is going this season if you're one of
those people that's hoping for like
stuff like this to happen they are doing
a lot more comic book storylines so I
think the chances have increased
dramatically
next question Nikhil asks why did Glen
have to empty out the shop if they
didn't need to do anything inside it it
was pointless wasn't it when I wasn't a
pointless they wanted him and Nick to
have that moment I think that's the only
reason that that whole thing existed
just so they could have that save it was
really almost more of an art for Nick
like they wanted him to turn into a good
care
in order to do that he had to have that
safe so they kind of had to be in this
this dangerous situation on their own so
I think that's why they had to clear
that job
next question notebook asks did anybody
else not see Aaron or Carl on this
episode I couldn't spot them or Rosita
Rosita
was in the infirmary and I we saw Aaron
in the flashbacks Carl too I think but
in present day they were just off doing
other things but thank you so much
everyone for so many questions he's
always a ton of fun to do
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner - danielle mark you win a $20
Amazon gift card just private message me
on the back end of my channel so I get
your contact info so there's gonna be a
new round of the giveaway whenever I
post my episode 2 video there was such a
big cliffhanger last week you could
almost view it as a two-parter - these
first two episodes so we're rolling into
the weekend Maisie Williams from Game of
Thrones is going to be on Doctor Who
tomorrow so even if you haven't watched
Doctor Who before I would advise you to
watch this episode it's gonna be a lot
of fun Maisie Williams is a total badass
I also still need to do a flash arrow
Q&A and there's a there's a bunch of new
footage so I might do a new trailer
video for that - that would be Saturday
night so everybody get pumped and and
don't worry there will be new Game of
Thrones this weekend - lots awesome
stuff happening so in case you guys
haven't seen it you can click here for
all my Walking Dead Season 6 videos and
you can click here to learn all about
poke being in Thor Ragnarok thank you so
much for watching everybody
what's up I've I'll see you guys tonight